today i just kind of ate home this all
day long so it probably made it a lot
grosser
thanks p.a thanks thanks it's production
assistant you're part of the lower class
now that's what just happened you're
here to react for me that's it i need to
know if i'm doing a good job what are
you doing you're talking to me
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
my neighbor maria's here ridiculous
the lego movie this film is beyond
badassery i just was not expecting a
film
this great it like blew me away i was
like
blown away it blew me
away trying to send a telepathic message
here marie approval
approved funny on camera there's just so
much about this film that i absolutely
loved okay i'm going to rattle them all
off for you right now i'm going to run
out of them the animation whether or not
you actually think the story and
characters suck you cannot deny the fact
that this is some of the best animation
cinema has ever seen this film is a
child's dream
come true and if you're not a child
it'll bring out your inner child and no
i am not talking about the first time
you had a wet dream you pervert
that joke did not make sense to me when
you're a child and you have a wet dream
i feel like i didn't have a wet dream
until i was like 14. okay
every aspect of this film right down to
its giant set pieces
to even just like the [ __ ] sidewalk
looks like
lego pieces put together it's better
than legoland
a lot of things are better than lego
land league one actually kind of sucks i
love
legoland there was not one time where i
got pulled out going oh that's obviously
computer effects like the best way to
describe it is just pure attention to
detail like i i don't know the technical
animation words because i don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] about that but yeah it's
brilliant the directing slash
cinematography and writing was just
incredible like the hulk
oh that could have been a lot better
marie so yes the animation
superb but it's not just the animation
that's great the [ __ ]
story is awesome what i thought about
what before i saw this film was how are
they gonna actually tell a good lego
movie that could
satisfy millions of people because you
know like legos deal with like
anything really they took total
advantage
of the fact that they deal with like
everything there's like fictional
characters there's historical characters
there's all kinds of characters
life is full of many colors in this film
the multi-universe
multi-universe or multi-universe as
gently pronounced in the one
oh hardcore asian fans are gonna
appreciate that one it doesn't make you
feel random because the story actually
makes sense for some reason like yes
there's a lot of like
randomness in the film it's little zany
little loony toony even a little family
guy
but at the same time it's not like so
random so like i guess that doesn't make
it random i don't know how to really put
it but just know this
the movie is funny as [ __ ] it's funnier
than [ __ ]
actually fucking's never funny unless
you're [ __ ] me
it's always a laugh riot when i'm around
ain't that right murray by the way
should've warned you kids if you're
watching
continue watching i haven't laughed this
hard nor
that consistently in such a long time
out of all movies of an animated movie
like if you you know smoked a lot of
weed and then
you caught the film it would be
hilarious
ask me how i know that but the film is
not just funny like especially in the
last 30 minutes there's some very like
touching
moments but it never loses the funny you
always got to keep the funny the funny
is the most important thing
what are you doing see that's funny
another thing too the cast
is perfect chris pratt as emmett this is
the average joe of our story he is
overly optimistic why because everything
is awesome
it's a song in the movie that song
defines the entire movie i got used to
seeing chris pratt play like you know
supporting characters and stuff
to see him as the lead in this film he
is awesome
sure it's an animated movie but no no
you're wrong about that
chris pratt does bring this character to
life in a three-dimensional way
elizabeth banks is wild style man
elizabeth
banks more like elizabeth bangs ryan
huh with this character they introduced
the master building
thing they do where it's like they can
assemble legos incredibly fast together
they can turn it from like a car into
like a spaceship all this it's
it's some of the most awesome [ __ ] ever
because the whole time it looks like
real legos are being put together it's
like
transformers but with legos but way
cooler than transformers
a lot of things are cooler than
transformers and they also introduce the
action with wild style and the action
is [ __ ] badassery will ferrell as
president business and there's something
to say about will ferrell no one seems
to like the [ __ ] guy anymore i think
he's still really funny and he proves it
with this film and no i was going to say
this for emmitt but tonight i'm going to
say it in respect
standing ovation for will ferrell to
show him i still love him i would
totally
suck will ferrell's lego dick he's the
main villain in this and there are some
truly
laugh out loud moments yeah me l o
ellie r o f elling morgan freeman as
god forgot the character's name you know
you hear morgan freeman in a film that's
like really funny and you expect like oh
his character is one that's not gonna be
funny he was cracking me
up man and he did it without making any
black jokes as we all know black jokes
are the best i got one for you two races
two races
[ __ ] oh nothing like a good black joke
lee neeson as bad cop he was [ __ ]
hilarious
my daughter she was taken remember that
movie i'm an american
by the way i don't recall seeing this
guy in a comedy before and he was
[ __ ]
awesome dude like he you wow
liam neeson has a new career ahead of
him he went from like oscar-nominated
actor
to 55-year-old action star now it's
gonna be wacky outrageous comedies the
christopher walken death charlie day as
benny he's not in the film too much but
he has some of the best
lines he's so funny charlie day is
hilarious it's always sunny in
philadelphia and guess what people
i was on season one and it's always
sunny in philadelphia that's right look
it up
tracking to find me under ryan wright no
that was somebody else then now from an
audience perspective i bet you're like
why hasn't he mentioned that one guy the
one that everyone was looking forward to
was he not good was he not a standout
no i'm just saving the best for last
willownet
that's batman you know how a lot of
trailers will show you like the best
character but then show all of his best
[ __ ] scenes
that is not the case with this movie he
was also hilarious he's super freaking
cool he's like an egotistical douchebag
in a lot of ways it was a great way to
portray batman because he he wasn't an
idiot but he also happened to be a big
dick at the same time he probably had a
big dick will our knight did a perfect
job and there's a song by batman in this
film when the movie was done i
swear everybody was singing that batman
song
everyone it was weird pick a category of
filmmaking this movie just
nailed it the grip on this film was
excellent best word to describe this
film
experience it's a truly cinematic
experience it's more than just
a great movie it's like going on a
journey let me get straight to the point
here
all in all i gotta say the lego movie
guy it's super duper
right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for the lego movie why don't
you go ahead and scroll that comment box
below
and tell me did you ever have a boy lego
toy and a girl lego toy
have sex with each other and if you want
to see more of my episodes
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
or videos is out go ahead and click on
this button with my dick to subscribe
that's right the penis
let me tell you something about this
little lego you could build
all kinds of things with this bad boy
like a baby nine months from now